i look around i see the people in the
stands and you know what for what we can
do this place is sold out so let's get
it rocking the best we can let's watch
some baseball schmidt led the club in
o.p.s last year 883
big gap in left center hits that high in
the air out to deep right field it's at
the wall it's off the top of the wall
goldsmith on his way to second base
and standing up with a double and he
missed a home run by inches or diddy
nope we've got the first home run of the
season off the top of the wall
didn't take long they'll get into a ball
game drive a baseball and then we get a
replay
right off the top of the wall and that's
the you mentioned the bullpen right so
the bullpen saying dinger uh he's saying
no no chance that thing didn't get out
of here
and it is a double for paul goldsmith
the big acquisition for st louis and a
chance to make an impact right away
nolan arenado
arenado hits it up the middle diving
stop
that's india to keep it on the infield
so it's a base hit his first as a
cardinal for nolan arenado the o1 pitch
to paul deyoung
fisted it right side base head goldsmith
will score one nothing cardinals
and arenado to third
17th straight opening day started
catcher yadia molina
and yachty is swinging
and it's under the glove of suarez and
into left and two runs will score and
it's a three-nothing st louis lead
dylan carlson is the seventh cardinal
batter to open up the season in the
first inning the pitch is swung on and
there's a high fly ball that's it deep
right field and it's a goner for carlson
dylan carlson with a three-run homer
six-nothing cardinals in the first
inning can't script it any better
this is the kind of momentum you love
seeing we'll see a few of them here
and a fly ball out to right williams
back and he makes the catch crashes up
against the wall
wanker tagging up
and he'll stop at third
terrific playing right justin williams
it was a very good play and he justin
williams hits the wall very hard here
you see his body just jar as he hits it
bounced in the dirt the wave to winker
and he scampers home the reds are on the
board
a run in two outs the pitch suarez
swings and he goes down on strikes
missing a cutter from flaherty but
goldie is on second base just like he
was in the first inning here's aronado
orinato breaks his bat and a base hit
into center
goldsmith
being waved in he will score nolan
orinato his first run batted in as a
cardinal and he's two for two on opening
day
this is really neat beautiful tribute to
both
lou and bob and the spikes of
jack flaherty here's a one-two
swing and a miss so just be on the
lookout for that
3-2 and
that time he got him
3-2 and he struck him out
fourth strikeout here's castellanos hit
the ball hard his first time up 1-1
that's rope to left field o'neal spot
around bye-bye baseball
nick castellanos
launches a two-run tater
and the reds get a couple more back it's
7-3
and the 1-0 pitch hit the other way base
hit goldsmith
flaherty to third he'll be waved in
he will score easily paul goldschmidt
his second hit
and it's now an 8-3 st louis lead
goldschmidt the runner at first base
tommy edmond at third
wild pitch gets away here comes a runner
to score and that adds to the cardinal
lead it's down 9-3
and i would think that this will
probably be the last inning for castillo
if he can get through it
headlong dive tumbling grab
sensational play by senzel
we hope nick didn't hurt himself out
there and uh
but he certainly showed you some
athleticism right there got a good jump
on that ball and laid out
out to deep left and goodbye
tyler o'neal
two-run homer
he hung it
and all of a sudden tyler o'neill jumped
on it
two-run shot and the cardinals have an
11-3 lead
there you see the looseness for flaherty
who
has homages to cardinals pitchers launch
lost and that one is launched day
johannio suarez to deep right home run
[Applause]
and the good vibes continue the
shortstop makes it 11-4
2-2
in the air shallow center gets down base
hit winker scores the fire from carlson
castellanos held it third rvi base knock
for joey vano 11-5
has that larger frame but works with a
softer touch base is loaded
first pitch in the air center field
carlson in
makes the catch tag from third the fire
home no chance castellanos streaks
across sac fly rvi it's 11-6
well we've seen this guy castiano's come
to the plate three times today every
single time he has hit the ball on the
nose bases loaded one out
line drive
caught by o'neal
his throw will come into second and
it'll turn into a double play
they run themselves right out of the
inning it's a double play
and they run right out of the inning
season debut everybody excited about
this young man healthy ready to roll and
that is alex reyes
and vato
lifts a high fly ball
into center with room carlson makes the
catch
they'll be in miami
going out
tommy edmond to make the catch and
there's two away
perfect that quick arm gets through
one-two pitch swaying and a miss he
struck him out
reyes blew it by him and the cardinals
win the first game of 20-21